we are here at comic-con mega64
represent in san diego style that's our
hometown we got a booth here selling
shirts we got our show on DVD we got
posters conference we got it all it is
like all of this we got stacks we're
stacking buckets this is the number one
booth that call me on the man and care
about them we got the hottest exclusives
at the show people lining up here we had
to there's nobody here right now because
security made him leave yeah that he had
to disperse to fire hazard I don't know
about you I'm excited about Metallica
being here because that is my favorite
comic and I think Stanley did a great
job when he designed amity
ter yell out in it yeah he drew it
Stanley drew and wrote his dude Game of
Thrones you know the police is going to
be there shoot that's cool dragons may
be there that's the spoiler you're gonna
show they're gonna tell you they're
gonna take things about the books that
are real secretive they're gonna be like
wow if you read the books you know what
also Rosco got a hundred dollar power
ranger Morford I did so how exciting is
that we were is it back here this is
worth the sorta way this is worth the
wait 30 hearing aeronca this is what
comic con is all about right here $100
I'm letting you know all you ladies who
watch go on new media rock stars just
you gotta you gotta rock star right here
it's me by the way ladies I am available
you call me up I will more white ranger
what green you let me know we like put
this on the front of new media rocks i
want to see this on both sides of the
columns put me as a background
permanently I don't want to see like a
week to change up thank you very much
get that squeak out that thank you I was
tackled by security because they thought
I want a poster tube which I did not
want I wanted to get out of there as a
matter of fact and you tackle me saying
I can't get a tube and I said good leave
me alone call Maccon staff is a great
bunch of people really call them great
comic own security of juices to solve
things with pushing some of them there
are some bad eggs some bad eggs in there
and every dozen there's a bad egg but
you got to break a few eggs if you want
to make a goal omelet ladies any groping
that goes within our ten by ten space is
consensual yeah we're allowed to again
you know sean is married but i don't
know did you get the okay to participate
well she's that girl men not women oh
alright well we're equal which is he now
yeah we're fine thanks Jenny yeah Jenny
you're open-minded that's what I like
about you
marry you I would that's still afraid
I'm you will see all works out yeah well
player thanks again hey thanks for
checking us out at comic-con again come
by the booth we're going to be a pax 2
we're at every big convention if there's
a big con and you don't have us there
you ain't a big con sorry should we make
it break it man I'm looking at you ready
baby look at you oughta con why are we
there edit submit the forms but next
year next year so you might as well
postpone it by the way once again ladies
you know that I'm here and Dragon Sword
I don't even need to take it out of a
box tomorrow yeah yeah that's how
serious I'm good comic con suction from
home whatever you're doing